this is a production of Cornell
University
thank you thank you for the introduction
and thanks for having me as you can tell
from the title there won't be many plans
in this talk so I thought put in at
least one slide with plants so these are
plans that we actually have in the lab
we we don't work on them but we like to
have them and obviously since you guys
are playing scientists you must know
everything about plants does anyone know
what this plant is it's an interesting
one this is yeah Amorphophallus titanum
the corpse flower so we have a bunch of
those in the Institute now I have one in
my office as well they're tiny and cute
as a baby I don't ever want to see it
actually flourish and build a flower but
for now it's fine I'll make this a
little louder maybe that's better
so I yeah okay but it does work okay so
my lab focuses on some very basic very
simple observations and fundamental
bacterial cell biology that's basically
what we do and one of those observations
is this one which is when you put a
bacterial cell like an e.coli on a bit
of lactam antibiotic and you can see
that the cells basically digests
themselves and disintegrates and there's
a lot of interesting biology behind this
very very simple process and we do a lot
with that it also has some obvious
biomedical relevance because the
beta-lactam antibiotics that kill the
cell if effectively here are among the
most widely prescribed antibiotics in
the US and most of you especially if you
have kids have probably heard of
amoxicillin this that's usually given
against otitis media in the form of
augmentin where the active compound or
the main act of compound is amoxicillin
so one of the questions we ask is what
keeps the cell from digesting itself and
exploding when there's no antibiotic
around well most cells have some sort of
a cell wall that surrounds the entire
cell and contains these pretty severe
intracellular pressures that bacteria
elaborate so some of some bacteria
actually have intracellular pressures
that equal that of a bike tire
and they have this strong cage all
around them that keeps it all together
in this cage is you can already see
consists of these these polymers that
are cross linked with each other these
polymers are actually polysaccharide
strands and these cross links are short
peptide bonds between them and we know
quite a bit about how bacteria
synthesize this whole cell envelope this
whole cell wall it all starts in the
cytoplasm or some precursor molecules
are produced so these are disaccharides
with a pentapeptide site stem and those
are then flipped to the outside of the
cell with a by a specialized translocase
called merge' and at least a model
organism e.coli
and then those precursors are picked up
and woven into the cell wall by two main
reactions one of them is a
glycosyltransferase and that is taking
these disaccharide subunits and
connecting them with each other so you
get these long strands of polysaccharide
the second reaction is transpeptidase
activity whereby the cell cross links
these neighboring strands by these short
amino acid side steps so first there's
some elongation of the material
polysaccharide chain formation and those
points Ackroyd chains are then basically
knitted together via these little
peptide bonds and you already notice
that this all starts with a single
pathway and the translocation is a
single pathway and then it diverges so
then all of a sudden we have two enzyme
complexes the LPO a pvps and the rod
complex with B pbps
that engaged in these activities like
acyltransferase and transpeptidase in
the APB piece which stands for class a
penicillin binding protein should
already be clear what the target were
what what these things are useful for in
terms of drug development the air the
Class A Penniston binding proteins have
both glycosyltransferase entrance for
the prepare today's activity in one
protein the only thing they need is in
gram-negative bacteria an outer membrane
localized activator without the
activator they're toast
the other side we have the rod complex
which is a bit simplified here it's more
than just this one protein there's a lot
of proteins that are in this complex but
the main ones are wrought a which
possesses glycosyl transferase activity
and a BP BP a Class B penicillin binding
protein which only has transpeptidase
activity and of course one of the big
questions in the field is why these two
right why do we have two very different
enzyme complexes that do exactly the
same thing one hint towards what they're
doing is if you look at their
localization I hope you can see that
maybe you can so this is just a
time-lapse a short time lapse of cells
that Express labelled components of
these different complexes if you look at
MRI BM SF GFP which is a member of the
rod complex you can see how these
symbols into these false eye that sort
of slowly rotate around the cell it's a
bit like a tabloid newspaper I'm telling
you what you're supposed to see here
right you're supposed to see rotation
but this has actually all been
quantified and it checks out this is
actually rotational movement around the
cell if you look at PB p1 am sherry
obviously an AP BP that there's no
particular pattern to this so basically
these just diffuse around in the cell
and if you look at these as this has
been done in e.coli in another model
organism look at these at the single
molecule tracking level you will see
that they basically diffuse around a
little bit and then they stop for a
while and then they go on diffusing so
these things biochemically do exactly
the same thing but they localize in very
separate ways and they seem to be very
separate complexes and I think so far
all of this is sort of known intuitively
boring because it's known so what we're
really interested in is how all of this
leads to growth and how the bacterium
deals with an interesting paradox the
paradox is this you have this cage that
contains a huge intracellular pressure
if you take away the caves the bacterium
dies and yet this has to be really
really flexible because bacteria have to
grow for example most bacteria I'm
talking when I say bacteria I typically
mean model organisms there's of course a
variety of different strategies
model organisms they start off as a
short cell they elongate and in the
process they have to deposit new cell
wall material in the sidewall then they
make a new cell wall in the middle of
the cell and then they have to cut that
in two so you end up with two equally
sized daughter cells and you can tell
from this that just cell wall synthesis
it's really not enough to explain this
here's the reason so imagine you have
these pathways precursors come in they
get assembled into the cell wall all you
end up doing is you increase the
thickness of your cell wall if this is
everything that that's going on right
and that doesn't help actually elongate
anything so unsurprisingly there's a
whole different side to this which is a
variety of enzymes that can actually
break the cell wall there are four main
families they're often hugely redundant
in bacteria the amédée --ss that cut
away the peptide site stem from these
polysaccharides friends the lytic
transguy cost laces that cut within the
police saccharide strands and the
endopeptidase is about which I'm going
to tell you a lot today and that
basically cut within these crossings
these are often referred to collectively
referred to as Collison's because if
they are uncontrolled they can lead to
cell lysis and there they're able to cut
the cell wall Occulus in various
positions
we know that these exists of course
because of something in experiment I've
already shown you if we use a bit a
lactam antibiotic what we do is we
inhibit the penicillin binding proteins
which of course bind penicillin and are
inactivated as a consequence and now all
of a sudden the action of these artisans
becomes apparent here's another example
of where we see that
so we inhibit cell wall synthesis this
is meropenem ease also beta lactam
antibiotic and your average e coli cell
will lyse and die and my model organism
the Brokaw Larry does something really
cool
it doesn't lice and I instead it will
crack open spill out its guts and then
form these sphere PLAs like structures
and what happens in these two images or
in these time-lapse is exactly the same
right the cell wall gets degraded by our
tolerance but here you still have a cell
in here you don't and where cell
biologists we need a cell so this is a
perfect system to actually study this
process but it's not possible in e.coli
where everything rapidly falls apart in
the cell gets destroyed as a little site
note
but we've noticed that this is also an
interesting or potentially an
interesting mechanism by which bacteria
can resist treatment with antibiotics in
the clinic and collaboration with Lars
west blade from Weill Cornell we
obtained some clinical isolates of
gram-negative bacteria exposed them to
carbapenem antibiotics and we found that
many of them and trabecular ka muffler's
influenza except CLI Rajan is in
pneumonia
also form these fear of blasts and if
you then wash away the antibiotic these
fear blasts actually rapidly come back
to life in form of micro colony again so
this might allow them in the clinic to
actually survive antibiotic exposure so
we we think this is a mechanism of
antibiotic tolerance as well now I want
to point out humilis influenzae since I
already brought up otitis media this is
one of the causative agents of otitis
media and maybe this is the reason why
otitis media actually is sometimes
difficult to treat
not because of resistance but simply
because he marvelous hangs in there is a
sphere class after his course of 10 days
you stop taking the antibiotic and it
will start growing again so
the normal function of all these little
enzymes it seems kind of like playing
with fire right why do bacteria have all
of these around well they are important
as I already suggested in various growth
processes for example we know this very
well the Amadeus that cut the peptide
site stems here are important for
daughter cells separation and this is
sort of known from E coli as well from a
variety of organisms that seems to be
very well conserved if you delete a
Maday sious in Baroda only one instead
of these nicely separated daughter cells
you basically get these long cell chains
cells are fine they grow fine but they
can't separate anymore so they stick
together so seemingly the acceptable PG
that is produced in these cells can be
cleaved anymore and more recently Gretel
in my lab figured out that you need a
second factor it's not just the Amadeus
you also need lytic trance-like
oscillators to cut the septum because if
you knock out all the little currents
catalysis or two that matter in this
case you also get these long cell chains
so we think that the septum looks
something like this we have a shared
peptidoglycan cell wall between these
two cells and the amma days is of course
can do most of the work but the amma
days is cut here between the peptide
sites them in the polysaccharide strand
so what if you have a polysaccharide
strand that stretches from one cell to
another well then you need the lytic
trans-baikal ASIS and these sort of come
together to resolve the septum the I
think most important autologous however
are the endo peptidases so these are all
zinc dependent enzymes which will become
important later and they're important
for cell elongation and we know this
because we can knock them out there too
that matter there is synthetically
lethal with each other so we can knock
one out keep the other under control of
an inducible promoter as long as it's
expressed you can see here in time-lapse
the cells elongate divided and do what
they're supposed if we deplete this
endopeptidase so now so effectively an
independent you don't get elongation
anymore at some point you can see that
division actually proceeds and you get
you end up with these short stubby cells
we can quantify that so long Gatien rate
goes sharply down as we deplete shy a
and all you need to do is express phi a
back in and we get wild-type elongation
rates
so the the endopeptidase is are
important for young geisha why well we
think it's something like this however I
have to warn you this complex that's
shown here has never been actually
proven to exist and we don't think it is
actually a complex so let's take this as
sort of a metaphorical complex of
activities rather than of proteins
because the activities that have to come
together to enable cell elongation are
something that cuts out an old strand of
peptidoglycan and something that fills
in two new strands of peptidoglycan
three new strands of peptidoglycan it's
three because that's how the
stoichiometry works out so you can
actually measure turnover in cells and
it's something like three to one
and the endopeptidase this would cut
here right in these peptide cross links
and that's how you get cell expansion
because you can imagine if you cut out
these cables and then supply some more
cables here you get lateral movement and
that's how the whole cell you long gates
and we think that that's what the
endopeptidase is do it's a little bit
more complicated than that though
because we still don't know what the
relationship between endopeptidase
activity and synthesis do you actually
need endopeptidase as in order to
synthesize anything or can they actually
be uncovered and we have some indication
that there can be uncoupled because now
we look at a strain that's deleted in
all inner peptidases they're more than
just those two so now we took all of
them out and if you follow very very
simple experiment you just follow the
mass increase in these cells and without
any endopeptidase is there's still a
significant mass increase they don't
seem to care all that much right if you
look at these cells you will notice that
they just become grotesquely enlarged
but they still enlarge so they still do
something they still seem to incorporate
peptidoglycan cell wall material of
course within a peptidase you get normal
cell growth we can measure that we have
indeed more cell wall material and we
can also visualize the cell wall
material with a fluorescent cell wall
stain and indeed these things still
incorporate cell wall material but it
looks apparent so normally you would
expect something like that where the
cell is evenly fluorescently stained but
in these and new peptidase tootisha
mutants you just have this accumulation
of bright spots
and this is one of these rare moments
where I finally have some tools at my
disposal that I'm always jealous off
with a eukaryotic world because your
carry auric cell biologists seem to have
inhibitors for everything right so you
see a talk and they implicate some
pathway in something so they just buy
the inhibitor and condesa it easily
finally we can do that too because there
are very specific inhibitors for APB
piece and and for the rod complex and
this allows us to ask the question this
mass increase that we see without
endopeptidase
what is this that actually mediated by
one of these systems or both of them or
which one is more important and that
gives us important information about the
relationship between these different
complexes and the cleavage activity by
under peptidases and very simple result
we inhibit the APB piece complete
endopeptidase as and all of a sudden
there's no more mass increase and if we
inhibit the other system the rod system
you still get the same mass increase
meaning that whatever a parent
peptidoglycan incorporation that you
just saw in the previous slide is all
mediated by the APB piece or in other
words without any peptidases
the rod system is completely useless and
this sort of explains some of our
phenotypes with the antibiotics right so
here's again this is a effectively a
wild type strain because it still
expresses 1 endopeptidase in Vibrio
cholerae you can see what I showed you
before you get this fear of class
formation and if we take away all the
end of peptidases and repeat this now we
don't get the mass increase anymore and
instead the cells try to elongate a
little bit and then lice and die so now
very local area looks a lot like e.coli
meaning that for the sphere of class
formation we actually need endopeptidase
--is to degrade the cell wall in a
controlled manner and we basically
already knew this since the 1980s that
endopeptidase and also lytic currents
keiko so laces are important for cell
wall degradation in the presence of
beta-lactam antibiotics it's just nice
to see that in a time that sometimes so
why am I telling you all of this I want
you to know that endopeptidase is our
major contributors to antibiotic
mediated cell wall degradation and
that's mainly why we study
because we want to figure out how
they're regulated I also would like you
to remember that sphere PLAs formation
the sphere formation phenotype is a
readout for toxic into peptidase
activity if you have too much on the
peptidases or if they're imbalanced
because you inhibited cell wall
synthesis you get serie blasts and now
the questions that we're asking in the
knob is how is endopeptidase activity
regulated under normal growth conditions
when we have no antibiotics how does the
cell actually keep all of this in check
and I'm going to tell you two stories
about this today one is a new peptidase
regulation is an adaptation so this is
genetic regulation of a new peptidases
this was just published in an bio and
then the second story is about a new
story that that we hope to get into by
archive next week or so about a
conformational switch that promotes an
intense activity so this is post
translational and open so the first one
as ever so often in science goes back to
an extremely simple observation you've
noticed by now that Vibrio cholera has a
lot of these impacted aces right and I
told you that to matter if ia inch I
seem but there's also a third one that
basically looks exactly like shy a inch
I see it's called try B has the same
domain organization seems to be doing
the same thing however it wasn't able to
sustain growth as you saw in the time
lapses we can't actually D try an inch I
see right so shy B is useless
we then notice that it's not actually
even expressed you put these cells on lb
this is a reporter construct for
promotion promoter activity Blue means
promoters on white means it's off you
can see that shy a and Phi C are
considered if Li expressed and Phi B is
completely off so what Shannon did my
grad student is something very simple
she took this reporter construct
mutagenize did with transposons
put it on a giant plate and looked for
mutants that now spontaneously induced
the promoter and this is something
that's actually quite amazing for gret
so and she did this basically within a
month of joining my lab and immediately
got something out of it and immediately
ran with it and within a year
less at a paper science doesn't always
happen like that but here did so she did
this and you can see in the sea of white
there's some blue colonies here and here
is a zoom in so some of these colonies
turn blue which means we found a mutant
that now induces this promoter and you
can see some are actually a little more
blue than others that was very excited
because I thought we got the master
regulator of endopeptidase activity
instead we got something called Zurn the
sir is weird
so there is a zinc starvation response
gene I'll tell you in the next slide
what it really does and the other hits
were in an operon is new Lucy is new
eight B and C and those were all the
hits so we drove this to saturation this
is all we got what does all this mean
while xur is as I mentioned a zinc
starvation response there is a repressor
that sits on certain promoters
controlling zinc starvation response
genes if zinc becomes limiting there a
release repression and the zinc
starvation response genes are turned on
part of this whole repertoire of zinc
starvation response is something very
intuitive zinc importers all right
you don't I think you ones Inc you pump
in zinc and there are two of them and
these if you may you may have noticed in
the last slide are our other hits so the
other has turned this primary zinc
transporter the difference between those
two by the way is this is a high
affinity transporter so this is useful
for high 4 low zinc concentrations and
this is a low affinity zinc importer
other zinc starvation response genes
include replacement proteins for for
example ribosomal proteins that
typically require zinc for stability so
this is all basically ensures that the
cell can sustain viability without my
disease around so it seems like the zur
record on also contained a cell wall
remodeling enzyme which was unheard of
and kind of weird so first we went ahead
and actually validated that that's true
so we looked at the promoter the scheibe
promoter added some v prime rays so we
know where the transcription start site
is and turns out the minus 10 region
an overlapping beautiful well-conserved
sir box and we would have never looked
for a zero box is there a binding site
ahead of this if it hadn't been for the
screen right so we validated binding of
the promoter with an M say si so this
just shows that the the that sir indeed
binds to the scheibe promoter so it
seems like all checks out and scheibe is
a bona fide zur ctrl-g biochemistry is
fine but I kind of like genetics so we
also wanted to see that that tech checks
out genetically we noticed that in
certain minimal media like m9 cells seem
to be starved for zinc and they turn on
sir and that's why the HIV promoter this
again the shabby promoter construct it's
actually on on an m9 minimal medium
plate if you work with bacteria that's
something you should probably remember
because I don't think people realize the
starvation conditions that they're
exposed to an m9 so in m9 the shabby
promoters on suggesting zinc starvation
we add zinc it turns off beautiful it
doesn't turn off anymore if we delete
sir
because there's obviously that would
pressor if you don't have it anymore you
can add as much as ink as you want
you won't repress the promoter anymore
because it's repressor is gone and then
Delta's new ABC in the in the zinc
importer mutant that would create it you
can still shut down
zinc Express promoter activity of
soybean suggesting that the second zinc
transporter that sort of one of the
tangents that came out of that seems to
be functional if you just add enough
zinc it'll it'll be able to pump it in
and repress this promoter at some point
and we can also quantify all this so
again in the wild-type you can
effectively shut down IV promoter
activity by additional zinc you cannot
do that in Delta zero of course because
the repressor has gone in adult has new
ABC now relying on zinc import by this
low affinity transporter the kinetics
are but less steep than for the
wild-type so then the question was if I
be really functioning as an
endopeptidase here or maybe does it
something else
well the summary of this is yes it's an
inner peptidase at least it can
substitute for fi ABC
vivo so if we look at these mutants a
lot of control strains but the ones that
matter are the Delta Phi ABC - I see so
these are all conditional they have the
other end of peptidase under inducible
control but it doesn't matter here right
now so Delta Phi a B is fine because it
says Phi C Delta Phi AC is not fine in a
normal growth medium because Phi B is
simply repressed Peyser however if we
add a zinc he later things turn around
so now we take away all the zinc try a B
Delta Phi a B can't grow anymore
suggesting that actually such IC is
inactivated somehow by the by the
absence of zing but now the shy AC
mutant can grow because we chelate zinc
we induce sir IB gets induced and
apparently shy B is enough to take over
and can do the job and can sustain
growth genetics is fine but I also like
biochemistry so let's look at this in
another way we wanted to test whether
Scheibe is an end up have to descend eed
and now I think it slowly for maybe for
you cut all comes together that we're
dealing with zinc dependent enzymes this
Inc starvation response usually includes
enzymes that replace enzymes that
typically require zinc might this be
something similar for Shai be my tribe
actually be an endopeptidase that
doesn't require zinc well we tested that
using biochemistry we can purify into
peptidases then take cell wall saccule i
and digest them in vitro and there are
several reaction products here I'll walk
you through them the most important one
is the soluble fraction so these
purified saccule I can be sedimented
with ultracentrifugation but and if no
peptidases start cutting away they will
cut the cross links right so they will
liberate single strands of peptidoglycan
and that would end up in solution and
you can measure that with you PLC and
then we add an enzyme called me Rama
days it's not really important what it
does but it creates basically diagnostic
cell wall fragments that allow us to
gauge the activity the specific activity
of these of these enzymes so this is
what this would look like focus on the
middle part at first so the first thing
you should notice is that try a B and C
can all digest something you can cut
something out of the saccule i right so
there's something in the soluble
fraction here and
the control or a an active site of shy B
you may also notice that looks a little
different between shy a and shy beam and
we don't actually understand that so it
seems to have slightly different
activity but in any case all of them cut
something and when we then digest this
within your AMA days revealing these
diagnostic Peaks we notice that this
reveals for all 300 peptidase ad D
endopeptidase activity so they're indeed
equal in terms of that the specific
activity seems to be a little different
but all of these have the same cutting
specificity all of them are the same
type of endopeptidase what we can then
do is we take the area under the peak
here and quantify reaction kinetics and
that's plotted here and then we repeat
this experiment in the presence of EDTA
and key layer of zinc asking the
question can these endopeptidase this
actually remain active without zinc or
without metals in this case because it's
not specific to Z and for shy a and shy
C the answer is no so if you had
increasing concentrations of EDTA to
these reactions activity activity gets
pretty rapidly shut down for shy C
earlier than for shy a but if we repeat
the same thing with Phi B it remains
completely active even in the in the
presence of very high EDTA
concentrations so shy B it seems to be
able to function either in the absence
of zinc or it just has an extremely high
affinity to say we don't know which one
it is yet we're working on that so we
still thought is kind of weird right
because the xored the zinc starvation
responds like most metal starvation
responses is very well understood so why
hasn't anyone stumbled across an
endopeptidase and all that and made the
connection to cell wall remodeling well
we think it's been overlooked because
phi b we're kind of lucky because our
model organism probably has the only
endopeptidase the only one we are very
aware of that has a sir box and its
promoter so it's more recognizable that
way but there are a lot of bacteria that
have something similar that actually
have other Z regulated genes likes new
ABC the transporter and just downstream
of that is actually an endo peptidase
that's homologous to Scheibe
and all of these organisms have that
suggesting that in the sink
starvation basically snoo a and this
endopeptidase our code transcribed and
there's some evidence if you dig very
deep into papers and their supplemental
data where people that are NAC gets the
analyses for your senior pestis and for
e.coli that's actually been shown that
zinc starvation induces this
endopeptidase and this is significant
because zinc starvation is something
that cells encounter frequently in the
human host so this is something they
have to deal with and perhaps tribe is
actually one mechanism of how to remain
viable upon encountering hosts pressures
like zinc sequestration and another
little thing Eric's car so many of these
papers the same day that this paper came
out his paper came out we didn't know
about each other but basically showing
exactly the same thing in a different
organism and that's really nice if you
get validated that way that someone
basically not only not actually
reproduces your data but shows exactly
the same in a very different organism so
this really suggests that this might be
widespread and important for
pathogenesis all right so that's
basically the genetic regulation part of
the talk I want to move on to something
that we're really excited about right
now which is conformational switch story
so I've always been puzzled by one thing
I've already told you that all these
artisans are potentially really really
dangerous right if you if their activity
goes out of whack they destroy the cell
the cell adjusts itself and dies however
you can clone these into a fairly high
copy number plasmid and overexpress
these in various bacteria this has been
shown in this case is the Ryoka Larry
but the e.coli crowd sees the same thing
and absolutely nothing happens so it
seems like you can really express
dangerous lytic enzymes and the cell
doesn't care
we made it care in an extremely
controversial topic lee in the inner
membrane and we basically cut off its
memory transmembrane segment and then if
we overexpress a deep deep deep into
this face under the stationary phase at
some point we see some sphere formation
which I've told you is indicative of
toxic and peptidase activity so we can
make these work suggesting that they're
not simply dead here but we really have
to blast it out of the water
so this all suggests that endopeptidase
activity in vivo is actually highly
regulated however what's puzzling is at
the same time you can purify these
enzymes and they're highly active
actually within minutes you can purify
saccule eye with purified enzymes like I
showed you two or three slides ago and
they're totally active so that's that is
it's kind of bizarre because the the
lytic enzymes the Attalla since that we
know about or the regulation of which we
know about they're all produced in an
inactive state and they're activated by
while specific activator proteins so if
you purify them they're inactive unless
you add the activator protein there
doesn't seem to be the case for the
endopeptidase is because they're highly
active so it could be that there's some
sort of a negative regulator but that
you would overcome at some point at
least you're doing rapid growth so it's
it's kind of puzzling right and I think
we understand this now due to a
wonderful collaboration with these
individuals so this is Marc saber at the
University of Michigan Eugen Mao and his
grad student Ellen here the while
Institute and in collaboration with
these two labs we obtained crystal
structures of endopeptidase and this has
really to me has really increased my
appreciation for crystallography I
always thought crystallography was sort
of the endpoint right he shows something
genetically and then then you prove it
with the crystal structure I didn't
realize they can also be
hypothesis-generating and that was true
in this case so the first structure was
boring the first structure is something
that you will see in the published
literature people have actually
crystallized and a peptidases and they
always see something like this
I'll just orient you here so this is the
n-terminus this would be domain one then
there's a domain two and a domain three
and the c-terminal helix domain 3 has
the active site this gray ball here
that's the zinc and this is where
peptidoglycan would enter and then be
cut the second structure was very
exciting we don't quite understand yet
why we got these two structures by the
way these were differentially tacked
this was tacked and terminally the C
terminally we think that maybe the C
terminal tag might have destabilized
this whole thing so it opens up a little
bit and you can immediately see that
this if you know something about the
mechanism of action of these enzymes
that this active site looks rather
closed there are these loops here that
occluded and everything's kind of closed
up and in this structure all of all of
this is a bit more open so the immediate
obvious hypothesis here is that this is
actually an active conformation and this
is an inactive conformation of an
impacted ace and what happens in vivo is
that some dramatic conformational
rearrangements activate these endo
peptidases were needed I want to note
here there's probably in vivo not this
dramatic crisp our crystallography
conditions might have actually favored
this so it's probably something in
between some slight opening and that
should be enough to actually increase
activity so this is if we look at the
active site in the in the open
conformation versus the cause we modeled
in a peptidoglycan fragment here so this
would be the peptide cross-linked and
the twenty saccharide strands will be
here and you can see in the open
conformation italy indeed the the active
site is nice and wide open so this
structure would actually fit in here and
in the close conformation it would not
but your cluded by for example this
residue but also by this gigantic domain
one that is not drawn here that would
basically reach into the active site and
close it up so we can test that now of
course with relevant mutants I already
told you cells don't care whether they
overexpressed shy a or not so this is
try a on a multi copy number plasmid
either unand you store induced and
there's not much of a difference between
those two conditions however if we
delete domain one which we predict to
inhibit function we get something like
this we get much smaller colonies they
kind of look sickly and I will not ask
you to believe that this is again
tabloid right I'm telling you what to
see here this is just for the Vibrio
aficionados you know that this is wrong
but if we actually look at these cells
under the microscope we see some
appreciable differences between either
active site mutant or expression
wild-type over expression and this you
get sphere formation at high degree of C
Reformation in some license so this
strongly suggested that domain one is
indeed inhibitory if you take it away
you get a more active enzyme deleting
one third of the protein is kind of a
crude machete type method of course so
we looked a little closer
what other mutations might favor this
open conformation and we looked at the
interface between domain 1 and domain 3
that's supposed to be inhibitory and
there are several residues here that
that are predicted to mediate some sort
of an agglutinative these two domains
and one particular one that's my
favorite is these two new scenes that
engage in some sort of a hydrophobic
interaction and they're embedded in a
sea of acidic and basic residues
respectively depending on the two
domains so we thought if we mutate one
of them to something charged maybe we
get higher toxicity for example real IC
and we did that and now cells get
completely obliterated by this mutant
protein and this was quite amazing
because this is an act this is a
mutation very far away from the active
site and domain one that increases
toxicity to a degree where we actually
get a plating defect so we were very
excited about that so now we introduced
a basic residue instead of this loose in
here and domain one oh yeah and this of
course also forms fears and check out
that way so now we can reverse that and
actually then mutate the other residue
to an aspartic acid so now this should
be glued back together right and indeed
it is or at least we think because we
lose toxicity of this immunity and if we
look at these cells they look totally
happy and healthy so this strongly
suggests that indeed these two domains
interact with each other and if we open
them up a little bit the enzyme becomes
more active we did this by chemically as
well again it's always nice to have a
combination of genetics and biochemistry
we purify these mutants and again we're
in collaboration with Philippa Calvin
Sweden did these activity assays and we
saw something that's a little bit
strange we still don't understand that
but first what we do understand is that
the wild type and we use the close
confirmation by the way the the
construct that yielded the close
conformation the crystal structures here
takes hours basically an overnight until
it finally digests cell wall material to
completion if we look at the L 109 K
mutant the hyperactive one it was in ten
minutes basically everything's digested
tweaking Li the L 109 KL 3 for 344 D
double mutant which was non-toxic in
vivo was still pretty talks are pretty
active in vitro right there is a
significant difference between these two
again suggesting that indeed this double
mutation reduces toxicity of L 109 k but
it's still pretty active and we think it
has something to do with the specific
environment in the periplasm of a
bacterium molecular crowding for example
that is better at stabilizing this this
close conformation and in vitro it sort
of artificially opens up here's another
mutant I just want to show that we've
tested a variety of mutants along this
interface between domain 1 and domain 3
and they all basically cause some degree
of toxicity this is the 1:12 iya gets
for your formation a little bit of a
plating defect or rather calling him a
morphology defect and one more thing I
want to mention is that the phenotype of
over expression of in the peptidases
is not actually just destruction of the
cell wall we noticed when we used our
cell wall stain that some of these
especially the Delta domain one mutant
actually it led to severe aplastic ease
in cell wall so they're fully surrounded
by cell wall and this is reminiscent of
our inhibitors if you inhibit the rod
system this is basically what you get
because the APB piece can still do the
job if you inhibit the APB piece
everything falls apart and that's closer
to the to something like the L 109
commute this is significant because
there is this old not-so-old actually
this realization that it seems like and
the peptidase is actually favored cell
wall synthesis activity so this is an
assay where people checked the cell wall
synthesis activity by the various by the
rod system in the a PvP system and they
notice that if you overexpress
and in a peptidase like map s in e.coli
you get an increase in cell wall
synthesis for some reason which is a bit
strange so there seems to be some
connection and i told you we're
interested in the specific connections
between either the rot or the a pvp
system with the end of peptidases there
seems to be specific connection between
shy a or an endopeptidase and the a pvp
system and this might actually explain
why we see this conformational switch we
think this is now gets into the very
speculative area of my talk because we
did a pulldown silac looking for shy a
interaction partners the hypothesis
behind this is that let's say there is a
protein factor that favors the open
conformation that induces open
conformation in shy a we should be able
to find it by pulling it down and what
we get is a lot of things but what is
the overlap between the two
endopeptidase aah I see is LPO B might
remember LP OBE from this diagram LP OB
is an activator of a PB piece so this
does suggest some connection between
Shai a and cell wall synthesis and the
simple working hypothesis here is that
Shai a only gets activated once and
interacts with the solo synthesis
complex and that's how you regulate
degradation and insertion of new
material without loss of structural
integrity we don't have much to go on
yet but we can use this horrible
phenotype from a few slides ago to at
least run some preliminary tests on it
so this shy C devoid of its
transmembrane signal induces here
information at some point so maybe the
reason it does that is because if we
overexpress it slowly it's a freely
floating in the periplasm it has more of
a chance to interact with its activator
LPO ALP OB which means that we repeat
this experiment in Delta L KU u OB we
shouldn't see it's your formation
anymore and that's exactly what happens
so that tentatively to me suggests
indeed that LP OB might be an activator
of endopeptidase activity anymore as
well and this would be a very simple
model then that you get this
conformational switch and the
interaction with the cell wall synthesis
machinery stabilizes that and activates
a new Pepsi basis since I work on a
non-standard non-model organisms fabric
Larry we always worry about convincing
the e.coli world I don't know how it is
in plant science is probably similar
their specific model organisms that
people follow and if you work on
something that's not found in these
model organisms
don't care as much so we checked does
this actually happen in other organisms
as well so we pulled out some ender
peptidases from varying organisms how am
i doing on time fine right five minutes
I'll go through this fast so we pulled
out some endopeptidase from various
organisms that all sort of look the same
they all have the same domain
organization and then we created mutants
there are expected to mimic this
activating phenotype for example from M
in e.coli we can cut off the main one
get full toxicity for a Neisseria
gonorrhea enzyme we can create a point
mutant in this interaction interface
between domain one and domain three and
again we get higher toxicity so it seems
like pretty widespread this mechanism of
activation and not just a weird
curiosity of the the real world and so
as a summary I've shown you that and the
peptidases are important for cell wall
degradation after antibiotic exposure
they're only required for the rod system
but can enhance a PPP function and
they're regulated in various ways to
ensure that the cell coordinated cell
wall synthesis and degradation so with
that I'd like to thank you for your
attention and I'll take any questions
you might have
[Applause]
yes but they're probably not very
interesting at this point because
they're usually in in our expression
system so we get mutant in our
expression system I've thought about
setting guns this up in a way to get
something more informative for example
you could have several plasmids that
that overexpress the toxic Shai a
variant so I think those would be very
interesting but yeah we haven't looked
at that yet for survival maybe just for
survival curiously not so this is a bit
weird it seems like phi a even though it
can be effectively shut down if you
remove it zinc in vivo it actually
doesn't seem that different from chai
I see is clearly the one that
unreasoning starvation conditions
doesn't work anymore and I always say
that these are synthetically lethal and
functionally we done them it might not
be entirely functionally redundant in an
actual and vivo situation try B is not
necessary for colonization of mice but
that's not a real disease model and we
would have to probably go into humans to
actually test this hypothesis so the
simple quest simple answers I don't know
and it's of course a question we're
really really interested in we've tried
several things curiously if you
overexpress try a in e.coli it helps it
a little bit so it will actually form
spheres in response suggesting that you
actually need a certain type of
degradation to survive this and I feel
like it might be something like in like
a balloon if you just pop it in one spot
it'll burst but if you maybe cut it a
little faster in a different way it just
slowly unravels and then you don't get
this pressure release in a longer tiny
tiny speck of cell envelope surface but
rather like the slow release of pressure
that enables them to stay alive but
that's not the only thing so there must
be something else outer membrane might
be more fortified in Vibrio cholerae
with some indications of that actually
might be the case but nothing definitive
yet to monitor the so bass or whatever
of these bacteria I mean aren't there
sort of effects the morphology of
bacteria yeah if you do play counts for
example do you see that there's not art
effect resulting from
so there are two things to this first of
all you're absolutely right
all these 600 readings are not reliable
with these weird morphologies but when
you say or when I say unreliable
that means there's no connection anymore
not true connection between CFU and in
cell mass right if you look at mutants
like that like depletion where they
actually died because they need
endopeptidase is then of course the
connection between CFU or between live
cells and and cell mass is completely
disrupted so basically the endopeptidase
mutants die when we deplete inter
peptidases but they still increase in
mass and they die I think because the
increase in diameter too much that they
can't go through cell division anymore
so we've done some experiments where we
let them recover if they're under a
certain diameter they can still recover
otherwise they can't this has been a
production of Cornell University on the
web at Cornell edu